running is an activity fundamentally
based on breath
you run as far as your lungs will take
you
if running long distance you drink in an
ocean of air
trying to extract enough oxygen every
second to keep going
for some people however just getting
enough oxygen in their daily lives
can be a real problem cystic fibrosis is
a
multi-organ genetic condition that
affects
over 10 000 people in the uk people
think of it usually as a lung condition
but it also affects um pretty much um
everything in the body
in particular the digestive system so
it's caused by an error
in a gene and i forget which one which
impacts the ability of the body to to
control the salt transfer through cell
walls
and this means that there is if in the
lungs for example this
means that the mucus within the lungs
kind of
dries out and becomes much thicker and
much stickier
and the body's normal use for mucus is
obviously capture
any kind of bacteria or particulates if
they get that low
and naturally expel them because of
how the mucus is that doesn't happen and
you end up with a
buildup of uh infections essentially
which over time cause lung damage and
scarring
members of my discord community or
viewers of my twitch channel will
recognize dan hanvey also known as
danvi for the best part of a decade now
he's been a very close friend of mine
and a key supporter of my work online he
was there
cheering me on from the very beginning
why do you support my work
so much is cf like covert is a symptom
that you
you lose your sense of taste just at
this point you know a sense of
compulsion that i can't get rid of
you've got stockholm syndrome into
supporting me
[Laughter]
come with me on my run this evening this
is my first time vlogging a run in a
very long time
yep still just a self-conscious also
pixel goes with me
when were you diagnosed with cf i was
diagnosed
shortly after i was born which is when
when the
large majority of cf patients are
diagnosed um i think it was only
a couple of weeks maybe three weeks um
essentially
i was born and i instantly started to
lose weight which obviously is not ideal
for a newborn baby so there were various
sort of tests run
the big one is a sweat test um because
of the
salt channel kind of cause of cf
you have a lot more salt in your sweat
um
and so they can actually use that as a
pretty good baseline of whether someone
has cystic fibrosis or not
we're very lucky to live where we are
and to have views like this to run along
also today was like the hottest day of
the year so far
and uh yeah we had to wait for a while
for the temperature to cool down it's
like 10 o'clock right now
it's like nine it's basically ten are
you recording
yes oh my god it goes
oh wow look at this whoa
wait we're not running this way oh my
gosh for the vlog though
any words we've got to keep moving our
muscles get sore
we've got another 10k to go come on
come on this is my medication shelf
um so this one is a
uh a powder that i inhale morning and
evening it's
called a mucolitic it just helps thin up
the mucus the blue box is an antibiotic
to suppress any infections that are
currently
sort of down there in my lungs i've got
pancreatic enzymes
i've got some vitamins because your body
can't absorb them
as effectively so you've got to take
supplements
holidays are great because you have to
like fly with a letter explaining
why your suitcase is full of pills
how many times would you say you've been
hospitalized with cf
god i i did count at one point
um up until about last year
it was at least two times a year since
the age of about
11 10 maybe usually it's some kind of
lung infection
um that has um got too much to kind of
handle with other
treatments and you have to go in for
intravenous therapy which is
a lot more intense a lot more sort of
actively managed
now gopros don't do very well in the
dark this is like a very well-known
phenomenon
we're about to go into what makes this
one special
oh look at the mist
hang on simon turn on tunnel vision now
it sounds a terribly direct way to
phrase it but how
how long does a person with cystic
fibrosis normally live
so the best way because obviously as i
said it's a spectrum the best way is
looking at average life expectancy
kind of through the years so i was
actually looking at this the other day
back in
1950 um i think the average life
expectancy for
a child with cf was about five and
that's just surely you know because the
treatments just weren't available
as more things sort of came on and we
understood the disease better and
how it affected the body um that
increased so back
in 1990 i think uh
the average life expectancy was in the
20s
as of this year i believe we are
currently somewhere in the high
40s um but
i'm not sure and that will obviously
vary but on a huge range of factors
um but what's important is that yeah it
is
it is a it is a life limiting condition
like ultimately unless
you know i have some horrible accident
it will probably be city fibrosis that
kills me
i wanted to pay back some of the love
and support danvy has shown me over the
years
so this year i'm fundraising for the cf
trust the fact that cf trust exists
means that there is a group of
uh sort of charities and organizations
globally
who can who can and do come together
to share research to share knowledge to
work
on uh global projects to look at
improving the life well-being and
life expectancy of people's cf like in
previous years when i fundraised for a
local cancer hospice and for
conservation charity dural
i'm going to do this via running a half
marathon i'm not a natural runner
having the athletic ability and
proportions of a bowling pin
so this will be a very tough 13.1
miles to run in the past couple of weeks
pixel girl and i actually moved to my
favorite city
in the world bath or she calls it bath
and i'm going to be running the two
tunnels half marathon which is
kind of unique it's the half marathon
with the most distance covered
underground
in the uk you literally run through one
of the big hills surrounding bath
if i'm able to see through the sweat it
should be a really gorgeous route
but hopefully you'll appreciate it in
the vlog that i'll film off the race
the money raised by the cf trust goes to
a few different things that they do a
few different causes
one thing is sort of grants and
financial aid
for the families of those who have
cystic fibrosis because
it does have a financial impact um on
your lives as
any kind of you know long-term
disability does the big one
of course is is research and that can be
as we've mentioned kind of research into
new drugs and new therapies but it can
also be researched
into kind of the associated things like
um mental health impacts on people's cf
and new forms of uh or effects
of different kinds of physiotherapy and
third i guess
um the funding goes to things like
campaigns so either raising awareness or
you know campaigning to to the
government to the nhs
um to to bodies which can help yeah it's
it's a varied a pot and there is so much
what they do and there's so much work
that they want to do that yeah
they know what they're doing essentially
this one is
personal to me i wouldn't be where i am
today and the amazing community around
my videos and my streams wouldn't be
what it is today without
dan and that means i owe a profound debt
of gratitude to the cf
trust if you'd like to help their
life-saving work and help people like
dan live their lives to the fullest
or just donate in advance of what's
hopefully going to be an interesting
vlog
please go to justgiving.com forward
slash
simon clark cf linked in the description
i've been training for a couple of weeks
now and at the time of recording the
half marathon is about a month away
and i'm not feeling terribly confident
about this this is this is going to be
hard
as well as donating if you could please
pray for my legs this is gonna hurt
please donate